and i just think it's hilarious when
people are like you guys are thinking
too deep about it but yet i can google
search the matrix change my life and
this video will pop up with 10 million
views and the guys like the matrix
changed my life changed the way i wrote
things change the way i think about life
is every hollywood movie seriously the
same story just repackaged over and over
again find out on this episode of led
live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us again at led live we're going
to be talking about a subject that has
already been talked about but i thought
it'd be good to do a nice little review
because it seems like if you watch
something one day and then next week you
see it again and maybe two weeks later
you see another example you just you
don't really get that big picture you
see it all together so i wanted to go
through kind of a review
of something that scotty started a long
time ago called the gnostic gospels
there is a video of that click down here
somewhere to watch that video but
it's it's a really good presentation on
the comparison of the truman show the
matrix pleasantville and how all these
movies are using a story of something
called gnosticism it's a this mythology
that's a twisted version of the bible
and so we keep seeing this same trend
over and over and over again i mean
every time we see a movie trailer we're
like there it is again and so it's like
how many times do you have to put this
in a video presentation but i don't
think a lot of people are really
watching like the older video the
gnostic gospels it's a really good video
it's kind of underrated i think you guys
should check it out
but i wanted to kind of go through some
of that some of the other ones that
we've talked about and then some new
movies so that you can see a pattern
so that when you start seeing new movies
come out you'll be able to catch on oh
yeah here they're here they're doing it
again they're doing the gnosticism again
so
let's look at the first example here the
matrix is a really
well-known gnostic movie these guys
don't hide it they openly will tell you
that this movie is
a gnostic theme
the the producers well they're not guys
anymore they're they're women that's a
whole different subject but neo
the word neo means new
and what is that
how is that significant
well i mean he's he's
his last name is anderson anders the
greek word for man so he's the new son
of man oh what is that new age christ i
didn't know that so
so so yeah he's like a new age christ
that's what we see a lot in movies is
the main character is either like a
general
generic person like humanity or maybe
adam or it's like christ
and there's always the the the character
that they're going after has all these
attributes of god but we're going to go
through some of that what what i wanted
to show here was it says neo is a former
blue pill rescued by morpheus together
with the crew of the nebuchadnezzar
interesting word there that's biblical
as a red pill he was prophesied by the
oracle to be the one
so who was prophesied to be the one in
the bible you know this is a this is
setting him up to look like he's a jesus
figure and you would think oh cool he's
the hero he's like jesus kind of like
the whole superman thing you know he was
sent from another planet to save earth
and they set him up like oh this is a
christ character but when you look at
their
their characteristics or the their
their mission is totally opposite of god
actually it's the inversion of christ
which would be the antichrist
so
in gnosticism there's a character called
sophia which is basically the feminine
version of the serpent in the garden
right she came and said to adam and eve
oh god is this terrible tyrannical
dictator that's put you in this prison
and if you eat the fruit you're actually
going to become wise like god and you're
going to be able to elevate to his level
and he's just trying to keep you from
having this secret knowledge so so in
gnosticism the the this particular
female or whatever voice wakes that
individual up that they're you know even
in a controlled society the gnostics
believe that like that snake in the
garden of eden is a good thing right
like i just it's inverted yeah it's a
good thing that that that you know they
were being controlled and that that
awakening allows them to step outside of
that that controlled environment yeah
when i hear that narrative i already
think of all kinds of movies you know
you're in this fake world wake up you
know
i was trying to see what it actually
said on here she assisted in the
creation of the material world when it
creates mortal humans she grants them
souls and grants them the secret
knowledge of the true spiritual universe
so they can be freed from
yalda boss influence which y'all devos
that's
was yeah was the creator god that
created the material world and um in
their
legend or whatever they they basically
say that that
he created the world to be evil like he
was like a mean
you know just kind of like you know
didn't didn't didn't make it a nice
pretty place but made it this evil place
which obviously you can see the
inversion because the creator god that
created the universe
created it perfect it was beautiful it
kept them from knowledge like putting
raising a child in a shed and there's a
computer with the internet right there
but you never let them have access to it
right imagine all the stuff they could
learn but no i'm not going to let you
learn all that stuff so you'll see
there's always a character that
is this sophia or
serpent character
yeah this is also greek
sophia's comes from the greek word mean
wise or sophos wisdom
so neo greek sofia greek oh okay
her pattern there
so
in the matrix series trinity would be
that sophia character she's the one who
uh let's see it says at the beginning of
the series she is the first mate on
morpheus nebuchadnezzar and serves
mainly as a go-between for him and the
individuals he wishes to free from the
matrix as the series progresses her
primary
importance as a character becomes her
close relationship with neo she is
skilled with computers and operating
vehicles both inside and outside the
matrix and in martial arts throughout
the series her original name
let's say oh what i wanted to mention
was so
trinity is a programmer and a hacker who
has escaped from the matrix
so she has figured out that this world
is a fake world and and she's a hacker
and she's you know woke up to this thing
and she's the one that's trying to wake
up she's woke that's right she spoke
so just so you guys see this pattern she
is the serpent or the sophia character
and
the the constant villain in here yeah
let's let's i mean i feel like we're
going so fast there's so much here
what is morpheus
morpheus is also a greek
oh it's morpheus is the god of dreams oh
wow really yeah and so it's interesting
here when you have morpheus the god of
dreams coming to wake neo right from
like from a dream right and what ship is
he on then nebuchadnezzar the king who
had
dreams right that had to be interpreted
also the king of babylon the king of
babylon yes the king of babylon so
there's little details like that and
it's like where where are you is there's
such a mixture of
mythology in the bible and it's like but
but why are you bringing the bible part
in you know that's what i find myself
asking is why why are we bringing
the bible in what does that have is it
just because the word nebuchadnezzar's
cool yeah or does it mean something you
know what's what's behind all of that
people say oh because america's just
been saturated with the bible well we
see it in anime
less than one percent of christianity
there and that's where people attack us
like you're you're attacking a a media
that doesn't even have christian
influence well yeah when it's called
neon genesis evangelion and it's them
versus the angels and everything it's
it's all there but they're choosing i
mean when you write a story you're
choosing the names you're choosing
locations you're choosing all of that
you're doing it on purpose
and so in this case if these things have
significance in other realms
you know that before you're choosing
that and that's probably why you're
choosing it
nothing is random chance in a movie i
mean everything is planned out
specifically for that i was uh
did some extra work on lost abc's lost
10 years ago and man they they had the
books in the hands of the person and the
things that were written even inside the
book if they were to ever open it said
something it wasn't just by chance they
wanted to know exactly what was going to
be and where was it going to be all the
time
cans in the back had words on it you'd
probably never see but they had to say
something specific it's all planned out
all planned out it's interesting to have
insiders on there there's yeah there's
and sometimes there's a lot of irony
isn't there a scene in the matrix where
in one of them i don't remember which
one they open a book and it's like a
fake book you know that you would have
on the shelf it's supposed to be like
empty to just to store something
and on the opposite page of you know
where you would store the empty thing
what there's a headline do you remember
what it says um it was the simulaca or i
don't know the name of the book actually
um not the name of the book like what
did it say on the page
across from it um i don't remember but i
remember talking about it when we first
saw it yeah yeah because here the book
was empty and it was it had something to
do with like
it was some kind of empty philosophy
it was it was interesting i don't
remember oh man it's gonna drive me
crazy but
we're working on a matrix project yes so
that's probably why it's more fresh on
our minds and so we've let that count
out of the bag
so coming soon and i just think it's
hilarious when people are like you guys
are thinking too deep about it but yet i
can google search the matrix change my
life and this video will pop up with 10
million views and the guys like the
matrix changed my life changed the way i
wrote things change the way i think
about life and it's like
and and you read the comments and
everybody's like yes it did the same
thing for me we make a video you guys
are thinking way too deep about it yeah
well the the videos they were releasing
for this newest
matrix installment um there was a video
i remember seeing that that basically
had a bunch of uh behind the scenes with
the actors and had counter reeves and
had her and some other people and they
were talking about the influence that
it's had over yes the world obviously
pop culture and it's pretty uh shocking
to hear i mean people say they changed
our lexicon like they changed the
language that we use and i mean this was
a powerful mogul of a movie we use the
word are you red pilling right now right
right
you
so the the villain in this is
is these uh agents it says agents came
to existence when the machines defeated
humanity during the early stages of the
machine world war
and upon the machines creation of the
matrix they were old enough to witness
the creation of the paradise and the
nightmare matrix prototypes so they were
in existence when the creation of
paradise and nightmare happen
and it says
uh agents were
sentinent sentiment centennial security
eradication programs created within the
source whose primary function was to
eliminate anyone or anything that could
potentially reveal the truth of the
matrix to its inhabitants or cause harm
to its system
their directive
effectively functions in parallel with
the role of the assassins and secret
police hunting down specific individuals
and erasing i.e killing them they serve
as a primary
as the primary and later as the
secondary antagonists of the matrix
series following agent smith's breakaway
from the group operating always in
threes
isn't that interesting they're always in
three so it just makes me think of the
godhead that's right they would actually
in the first matrix finish each other's
sentences and one would say something
another one would say the other one and
so yeah this this to me was a
representation of the the the actual
real godhead but but not only that and i
want to reveal too much because like you
said we're working on this this matrix
project and in the fourth one they
actually call
this matrix
deus machina which means
the machine god
i mean they're not even hiding it
anymore so
it's a latin
yeah
all right so that was just to kind of
fill you in on one example of gnosticism
in a movie and and one that's we're not
just seeing this we're not just making
this up this is npr news it is a secular
source
and they're interviewing the the makers
of the matrix and it says he explains
npr rick's car that his book is a
thought experiment thought experiment
this this isn't like oh it's just a
movie it's just for entertainment you're
thinking too much about it no a thought
experiment right this is the same thing
we see people do when they do uh social
experience right how is somebody going
to respond in this scenario and you can
get data off of that and see well you
know if somebody sees something bad
happen do they really act on it you can
get a lot of information from that
they're calling this movie or this book
a thought experiment based on the notion
that this reality is in fact a dream
world which goes back to the morpheus
god of dreams
if we act as if
it is true does that enhance our lives
and our experience and my experience
is that it does
that thing starts to make a lot more
that things start to make a lot more
sense when we begin to entertain the
possibility that we are in fact living
in a dream world controlled by invisible
beings see
right here i think they're letting the
cat out of the bag of of the the sort of
antagonistic
like
uh view of there's something still
trying to control us and we need to get
out of that control and controlled by
people yeah and i'm not overlooked and
loved by invisible beings right i think
that's going all the way back to the
garden of eden i mean the devil's main
thing that he was trying to convince eve
of was that you're
being controlled you're not allowed to
you know do whatever you want to do in
this world and i'm offering you
something more you can have freedom and
you can be your own god and all those
those simple things are
this is a more complex version of that i
just noticed your shirt dude that's
perfect for this episode
follow the right rabbi you can get that
on lightweight.shop
you know what's what's so strange about
that too just thinking about that
concept is
you know in the matrix it's like
if if you're neo or trinity or any of
your humans it's all about
getting out of that dream world getting
out of that computer world and living in
the real world that's where it's really
at and what are we trying to do now
get into the metaverse
it's like wait a minute
but it's getting to the verse for the
same reason
that you were just talking about because
it's a world where you can do anything
you can be anybody
there are no rules you know
so it's like
it's just even flipping that concept you
know it's like get out of reality get
into the metaverse it's like saying get
into the matrix you know that's where
that's where you need to be so strange
they go even as far as to say is this
idea is not new it mirrors the 2000 year
old spiritual tradition of gnosticism
we're not just making this up they're
telling us an early form of christianity
gnosticism maintains that the world that
we are living in is not the ultimate
reality says francis flannery daily who
teaches religion at hendrix college in
conway
arkansas i guess
it believes that the god who created
this world is not the ultimate god there
is a higher god a transcendent reality
goes on to say
in gnosticism the christ-like redeemer
brings the world knowledge in the matrix
the myth is embodied in keanu reeves
character neo also known as the one
in his book the gnostic or in his book
the gospel reloaded greg garrett a
professor of english at baylor
university says
the action and violence
of the film series may be the most
effective way to draw in crowds and
communicate a spiritual message in the
media in a media saturated world so
we're gonna put something that's full of
explosions and fights to draw people in
so we can give them this spiritual
message
religion and spirituality are
communicated to our culture by movies
much more than they are by the
traditional venues of synagogue or
church garrett says
a really good myth
does more than just create a symbolic
world it articulates the feelings that
the a culture already feels or believes
okay so this this statement that you
just read right here is sadly probably
true oh yeah and and i think that
everyone has to take a look at something
like this and say
that's the whole reason why you need to
be careful of what kind of movies you
watch because
this is the this is the the sort of
the the method that the devil is using
to get his messages across and it's a
very effective method that he's using
in fact they're recognizing that a lot
of more people are getting this message
than they are getting the message that's
that's coming out of the church so
notice he's a professor of english this
isn't some
pastor right this is an interesting
statement and gnosticism the christ-like
redeemer brings the world knowledge
it's fascinating because
you know when when the serpent came to
bring knowledge and he said to the woman
you shall be like god knowing
knowing what good and evil
god never intended for man to know evil
that's right this is assuming that all
knowledge is created equal it's not
there is knowledge that god never
intended
for us to know he never intended for us
to see the things that we see or hear
the things that we hear no pain to no
sadness we were never supposed to know
certain things and so bringing that
knowledge is not always a good thing
it's not so
yeah
put it into something tangible when i
was a rebellious teen
and i found out how to make napalm from
the anarchist cookbook i went out and
did it man it was like and that's the
thing if i didn't never knew how to do
that then i couldn't have gotten in
trouble by doing that stuff you know so
it's not always good to know things
so
we'll segue into star wars we have a
video on star wars it's almost 30
minutes that scotty put together on this
but i think it's interesting that
darth vader
is is dressed almost identical to the
high priest and he's the bad guy he's
the villain his name is darth vader
which is dark father so he is the father
he's the all-powerful ruler that's
trying to tyrannically dictate
the whole world
and
and in the buttons on his chest there's
actually hebrew written in there
and so there i think that this is not a
mistake or a coincidence i mean he's
supposed to be an alien from another
world why have hebrew written on his
buttons why is the similarity so similar
and then you see right here i mean all
his troops
are in white and uniform standing on
either side of him
and you can see the parallels there born
of a virgin yeah this next scene here
this is actually from the comic what's
in the movie as well but it says here it
says
there was no father in that first frame
he had no father it's unnatural the
chosen one you didn't know that he was
conceived by the midichlorians which is
like being conceived by the holy spirit
see back in the day i was a trekkie i
didn't know where star wars was
yeah he had no father and that was a
prophecy in star wars it was prophesied
that he did not have a father and that
when he came he would bring balance to
the force oh that's exactly right it's
actually here it says
uh anakin skywalker which is the
previous name of darth vader
was a legendary force sensitive human
male who was a jedi knight of the galac
galactic republic
and the prophesied chosen one so exactly
what neo was what's fascinating about
star wars is you know you have two sides
right you have
good and you have evil okay so so the
good guys are the rebels and the bad
guys are the
republic always fantastic right well if
you look up the definition of what a
royal republic is you know it's
i think it's the republic isn't it the
republic they call them the star wars
yeah
yeah so you you look that up and it and
it's basically a
like a kingdom that's controlled by a
sole supreme authority right yeah that's
the empire the empire that's what it was
the empire i was wrong it's not republic
it's the empire the empire's you know
controlled by a single supreme authority
and the rebels are you know they don't
go along with anybody's agenda but their
own
it's like well think about that
what is god god is the king of heaven
the earth the sea the fountains of
waters he is a single supreme
authority he's going to set up this
kingdom here and what has satan done he
has rebelled
against god
the empire also has a death star that
has the ability to destroy and destroy
the world which is not a power that
satan has it is only a power that god
has like satan cannot destroy this
planet completely he's only allowed what
god left so i don't want to spill the
whole video you guys should watch the
video but i will say this little behind
the scenes moment just because i think
this is really strange i remember when
we were working on that video
and
you had found some clips from joseph
campbell
and george lucas
so you've you found them like you
bookmarked them and you went to go
download those from youtube
the next day or a couple days he went
back to go get them
and it said the videos had been removed
okay which is it's like well that's kind
of weird the weirdest part though is
said it had been removed
by lucifer morningstar like 666. oh wait
i kid you not
no joke i wish we had a screenshot
it was bazaar yeah like they were
tracking who was down there it was like
this guy who keeps making videos
exposing us
so we have those clips we managed to get
them
but
but joseph campbell
yeah joseph campbell influenced george
lucas heavily and joseph campbell is a
huge gnostic you should see some of the
things that he says about god watch the
video it's got the clips so he was the
prophesied chosen one yeah and he was to
bring balance to the force and
he was a hero with no fear no fear fear
not
and of course he's called lord and all
these things
what i think is interesting is like
keith was saying that
the leader of the opposite side the
leader of the good side if you will is
the rebels
and
darth vader is his father right
everybody's familiar with this scene i
am your father so if darth vader is the
father of
the leader of the rebels that's
literally like lucifer
god is his father he created him right
and like like keith was saying the
rebellion is the side of the good side
join the rebellion that's interesting
age of the rebellion where do you know
where that comes from that's like
propaganda stuff oh this is this is
communist marxism right there
totally ripped that off yeah there was
artwork there's a lot of posters that
came out they were very iconic in the
vein of
you know this propaganda stuff it was
kind of like a joke they had both sides
or whatever but resist the empire
anytime you see a fist like that
like you just said the empire the
definition is
a large commercial
organization owned or controlled by one
person or group here
single supreme authority yes and when
christ comes he's gonna set up his
kingdom here and he is gonna be the sole
authority so another movie that we see
this same theme wreck-it ralph
you have ralph who is the satanic figure
sitting in the city dump which jesus
talked about the city dump gehenna
hell
and he's
looking you know this it's all to paint
this sympathy for the devil thing you
got and notice it's the top floor that's
all lit right everybody's up there
they're in the the highest floor of the
penthouse
up there where the clouds are and he's
looking up there and he just wishes look
he's covered in dirt he just wishes he
could join the happy people of what's
the name of this place nice land nice
nice land if i was like going to write a
fairy tale a fiction
book telling the gospel i'd call heaven
nice land you know where everybody's
nice
and they're following the nice carpenter
he is a really with a magic hammer that
he got from his father
this is all in the game all in the movie
and he can fix whatever's broken oh my
goodness so he's the good carpenter that
everybody follows but look at the
expression on this guy walking in he's
all mad and angry looking back at
uh ralph as he's all sad and he's not
accepted you know so it's this whole
sympathy for the devil and here's a you
know just another little
nudge that he is
the serpent he's offering the fruit
to a snake i think it's interesting or
these little demon looking things yeah
offering the fruit he meets the girl at
the tree
uh we have a video on this by the way
look at the wreck-it ralph video he
meets the girl at the tree because she's
wanting this medal that makes one like
felix felix is the good guy carpenter he
wears the metal so basically the metal
is like this
illustration of the the fruit of
knowledge you you take that and you
become like and what's her name again
penelope vanellope
vanilla bean vanilla
but she's she's a glitch so when she
gets the medal
that's supposed to make one like felix
that's the first time you see her on
screen glitch out
now the whole
thing in the movie is that the king
candy the king of the whole world of uh
candyland or whatever
he's saying we gotta get rid of that
glitch because if we don't get rid of
her the whole system is gonna get shut
down
sin yeah it's sin like we gotta get rid
of sin or else i'm gonna have to wipe
out the whole world there's actually a
scene where
uh it shows her and it's kind of like a
dream or something sequence and it shows
her up in the screen and you just see
all the world behind her like coming
into flames
because that's what god is gonna have to
do to wipe out sin he's gonna have to
to cleanse the earth with fire and so
she has this glitch
but by the end of the movie she actually
is rewarded for that glitch it's it's
the glitch that helps her defeat the
king helps her win the race because she
was she actually promised that she would
never use the glitch but when she got in
a certain situation she said all right
i'm going to have to use it to win
and she uses a glitch and it makes her
cross the finish line she becomes the
princess saves the day all the people
who are saying the rules are here to
protect us
now they're crawling on their knees and
thanking her
and ralph gets to be the favorite bad
guy
accepted by all the inhabitants of nice
land
which is very interesting there's even a
scene of him in the
um like sort of rehab or something rehab
again
and and and satan's sitting right next
to him yeah he's having a conversation
with satan and he says thanks satan yeah
yeah are you kidding me is that no no
it's in the hell it's called bad anon
it's like bad guys anonymous and he's
saying i wish i could be good i just
want to go up there and they're like no
no don't you can't be good you're going
to mess up the system you have to be bad
you were created to be bad
that's the whole object as a movie
embrace your bad side and then in the
end they're basically blending those two
things together yeah he wants to be good
but they say no you're created to be bad
and in the end they embrace them you're
our favorite bad guy he didn't repent i
don't know if you're going to touch on
this one but this is very similar to the
lego movie as well yeah
i think we're going into that a new
movie that just came out is called ron's
gone wild
wrong
he's glitching he's different
yeah yeah
and and i don't want anyone to get the
wrong idea from us like oh it's you know
you're saying you can't be unique and
all these things that's what they're
trying to to make it look like but but
the thing is is these
robots were programmed you can see
they're all white and they're all in uni
you know they're all perfect order
perfect order
and they were programmed to not be able
to hurt humans they're programmed to
have all these safety features basically
in the movie instead of everybody having
a phone
kids all have this little robot and it
can record it follows you around it
records you all these kids have their
own youtube channel
and it's like it's basically
it runs social media and everything but
you can ride it like a skateboard and if
it goes to the edge of a curb it goes uh
you know it's got all these safety
features to protect the child
now
the main character he wasn't able to
afford one of these so his dad bought
one in a back alley that was a damaged
one and he was this wrong guy who's got
a glitch and he doesn't have any of the
safety features he actually smacks a cop
smacks a bully and that's what gets the
attention of the creators the creators
and they're like oh wait there's one
that's doing bad things we got to
demolish it
we have to put them in the compactor and
the kid ends up going in the compactor
and saves him
and in the end of course ron saves the
kid
and hacks the system and turns all of
them
wrong all of them wrong and they all and
it's a much happier world then because
all these robots are way cooler now that
they have a glitch
so here's a here's a scene of how he
operates
what
[Music]
i am insert registered name's best
friend out of my box please connect me
to the bubble network
hi no what is wrong with you grand
princess you wanted it grand it looked
alright for new york 45 40
it just it doesn't work properly
what's happening i'm gonna destroy you
pulling my head off
incorrect i have no mega safety controls
and stuff
where i can see them
that's crazy at least i'm not uncle
for real upgrade them so they'd all be
like you
please connect me to the bubble network
[Music]
it's mad max meets sesame street live
streaming oh we think the safety
controls are off on all the box choose
your friends and i choose everyone
requests
so here i am again
18 minutes of recess
fun
wow you had to hack the system and make
them all
get rid of their safety feature and it
was a happy ending with the beautiful
piano music and everything
what is this teaching your children you
know
this is to be broken yeah so
moviespoiler.com
just gave a quick synopsis and i just
want you to see this isn't just us over
analyzing he says
graham later gets barney a bee bot that
is slightly damaged and it turns out to
be defective and destructive while
barney and ron start to become friends
bubble the company that has made the bee
bots catches wind of ron's existence
because he hit barney's classmate ridge
as well as a police officer the company
tries to have ron crushed but barney
sneaks him out
months later all the other kids have
bee-bots acting like ron
i mean i just don't
is everybody else seeing the same thing
i mean we've seen this in other movies
too that aren't included in here such as
what was the mega mind and um
it's good to be bad and all these things
it's like the the world is pushing ideas
out there that they're there is
this like
boundaries or controls and that that's
not really true freedom
and that if those are removed then you
know you can do whatever you want and
and i mean
same kind of concept is star wars it's
just star wars is not necessarily you
know uh uh
uh about something like that modern or
whatever but but but the rebellion
aspect is still the same
yeah go ahead yeah on a purely
psychological level what sells these
movies is and titillates the mind is is
what
the desires that everyone
has inside to do whatever you want right
and if you if you
you want that so you go to the movie to
try to
imagine that and and you're like wow
that was a great movie because it lets
you
produce that without actually doing
yourself so these things sell and it
sells and it sells until it mesmerizes
the mind until you do it yourself
that's the psychology behind this it
makes money that's right just actually
just enticing the brain to like want to
put yourself in that position just like
lady gaga said born this way
that's the way bibot or whatever this
bot he was born defective
ralph was born defective and he didn't
change they never none of these movies
ever show where something's defective
and we fixed him and make him right
actually in this movie
the um the boy ends up in the hospital
and they take the robot and they fix him
and they give him back to the kid he's
like hey i fixed him and he's doing all
the right things the robot's acting the
way he's supposed to and the kid's like
that's not him he's not like that and he
ends up i don't know how he gets them
fixed or whatever but another movie that
does the same thing that i didn't add in
here is the ugly dolls we got a whole
video on ugly dolls same thing you got
two worlds this colorful world of
everything's crooked and and messed up
and
all the characters are defective and
they got one eye and horns and all these
things and and they want to go up to the
big world the perfect world the
institute of perfection the school of
perfection that's ruled by lou and he's
like this perfect guy who's critical and
and when they go up there he's
constantly saying oh you're too ugly oh
you got a little blemish right there and
i just paint this picture like christ is
really critical of you and in the end
they defeat him they defeat lou and
merge the two worlds together and it's
called
institute of imperfection and
everybody's painting on their faces and
they're just running around and it's
always about merging the two worlds
together
so we're gonna go through
kind of a comparison here we we talked
about the matrix another movie that was
like the matrix had the same type of
characters as small foot we got a video
on that this is all kind of review guys
i just want you to see them side by side
because it's like if you see it one week
and you see it two weeks later and then
a month later you don't really get the
big picture like when i see it it's just
like man is there anything is there any
new idea or is it always the same story
over and over
the lego movie like keith was saying
same characters you got the new age
christ you got the sofia the serpent and
you got these godlike characters and
then the truman show
so to go through the characters that are
like christ you got
neo who's the new age son of man
you got migo who's your friend
amigo you got emmet who is truth they
said that the name really came from the
hebrew truth and you got truman who's
the true man and and these things aren't
to be like christ this is the gnostic
christ right that they're trying to
portray right they kind of make you
think it's like christ but that's what
satan's going to do he's going to come
as christ and deceive millions of people
and say no that's him all the characters
are there look but there's going to be
subtle things different about him his
agenda is different and it's interesting
that truman's sitting there with his
arms stretched out like that that's a
popular image of him the sofia character
is uh trinity in the matrix
this girl i don't remember her name but
she was actually the stonekeeper's
daughter so the villain's daughter tells
the main character that no this is all
fake world or whatever
uh this character wild style i think
wild style her name is actually lucy a
little nod to lucy fur there i think
and then the girl here at the bottom i
don't remember her name either but she
had
he thought her name was one name but she
said no my name's actually
lauren or whatever so again with the l
it was like her name was something that
started with an s and then it became
something with an l i just think it's
interesting satan lucifer
and then the bad guys you got the
the triune agents here you got the stone
keeper who's literally dressed with a
robe of stones with laws on them and
we'll see that in a video clip right
after this which movie is that a stone
small foot small foot he's the stone
keeper then there's
lord
business
who's you know
he's the lord of business and then down
here you have christoph or christ off
whose co-partner is moses who's living
in the moon watching everything that
truman does and he's the creator of the
television show yeah the creator so
we're gonna look at a couple of these
clips we're gonna look at how
all these start out with this perfect
world like eden
this is my world and i gotta say
it's awesome and the best part
everyone's happy that's because our
world is built on a foundation of stones
see we have these laws that are written
in stone
literally written in stone interpreted
and enforced by the stone keeper they
pretty much tell us everything that we
need to know the stones are here to
protect us and keep us safe
are you kidding interesting language
that he uses you know and it is awesome
the lego movie yeah it opens everything
is awesome you know
it's also how they end the movie
[Music]
good
morning apartment good morning doorway
morning walk morning ceiling good
morning floor ready to start the day
ah here it is
instructions to fit in have everybody
like you and always be happy step one
breathe
okay got that one down step two greet
the day's smile and say
good morning
[Music]
city
so again he woke up at a in a perfect
world everything was great he reads the
instructions his bookshelf has multiple
instructions on there on how to be happy
you know
how to have joy
god gives us joy right
here's truman's show same thing
good morning morning good morning oh and
in case i don't see you good afternoon
good evening and good night
give me a paper there will you errol
oh and uh
that'd be all for you truman that's the
whole kitten caboodle catch you ladies
good morning
hey good morning truman
good morning truman morning troops hey
how are you guys beautiful day in
always
and how's your lovely wife
always a beautiful day that odd little
interaction here was he's he lives on a
movie set and so they're putting some
product placement here for the camera
that's how they do their advertising
this is older movies so maybe not
everybody's seen it
but you see like the same parallels man
and there's so many examples we're just
trying to show some
like three of them but
so many movies that do this perfect
paradise paradise perfect paradise
and then you're gonna find out it's not
such a perfect paradise
so here are examples of the sophia or
the serpent character
in the smallfoot movie he's here
[Music]
michi welcome i'm really glad you're
here what is this place exactly it's
small foot evidentiary society you're
like a small foot club
and hold on you're the leader but you're
the stone keeper's daughter look i love
my father but he isn't exactly what you
would call open to new ideas because
questions lead to knowledge and
knowledge is power
wow
the stonekeeper's daughter is the one
who's telling him
oh my father again like
luke
which means light his father was the god
character her father is the god
character and oh he's not really
he's not really keen on new ideas
because new ideas are about knowledge
it's the insinuation of the serpent god
is keeping something from you
and who would you believe
you know more than the stone keeper's
daughter the one who's closest to him
lucifer was right there with god he had
a lot of influence in heaven he was a
covering cherub and so he was right
beside god lots of times so why wouldn't
you trust a covering cherub
higher than all the angels able to
convince a third of the angels that god
is a liar
it's amazing
[Music]
benny send this out to everyone in the
universe
hey everybody you don't know me but i'm
on tv so you can trust me
this is emmett
and he was just like all of you
following the same instructions as you
all of you have the ability inside of
you to be a groundbreaker and i mean
literally break the ground
peel up the pieces tear apart your walls
build things only you could build we
need to fight back against president
businesses plans to freeze us it will be
known
as freedom friday
wow
freedom to do what wow
break the rules break the instructions
because in the movie
lord business is trying to make
everybody follow the instructions and
she's saying no tear the walls up tear
the floor up do whatever you want
freedom friday
and it was supposed to be taco tuesday
but now it's freedom friday so it should
change the day even
and lord business actually in that movie
um says that if you don't follow the
rules we'll put you to sleep yeah yeah
kind of a you know another little slam
yeah on god yeah so here's truman's show
the scene with his um
serpent
sophia lady
[Music]
truman where they want listen to me
everybody knows everybody knows
everything you do they're pretending to
be do you understand everybody's
pretending no no no no but my name's no
more it's sophia my name's sophia
hey wait a minute who are you i'm her
father what i've never even come on you
weren't doing anything
please don't let him everything i've
told you is the
truth this
it's fake it's all for you i don't know
everything it's the secret i don't know
everybody don't be all right
please please he's gonna lie to you
so she said my name's not lauren it's
sylvia my name's not lucifer it's satan
i don't know i just maybe i'm looking
too far into that but the other
character's name was lucy but she went
by a wild style or something like
cameras wild something
so we see over and over the same same
parallel going on and now here it is
leaving that perfection finding out that
perfection isn't really something good
it's actually something evil and you
want to get away from that
the whole road
i told you the stones were here to
protect us so here it's
they they were convinced that the the
mountaintop they lived on was all that
was the only thing that existed they
they didn't realize that each of them
spoiler alert were
working for this machine that would
create cloud coverage so they couldn't
see the world below them and
when migo found out there was a world
down there he wanted to go unite you
know unite both worlds like always
and there was this battle going on where
the
somebody in that helicopter didn't want
this to happen so the stone keeper threw
all his laws he was totally against this
he was the one
creating the deception he knew about the
world down there and he created the
whole machine
that every one of them had a job in uh
making the cloud coverage he was the one
that knew all about it but now here he's
like
yeah you're right let's get rid of all
these stones he just threw them all away
and he he was trying to convince him
that there was a lie that he was trying
to make them all believe and that it was
a beautiful lie and that now he's trying
to convince migo that the lie was a good
thing because if you go down there
they're just going to hurt you or
whatever but that's just the the the
um reversal that gnosticism does you
know what i mean it's like they're
calling god the liar they're calling him
the one that's the one that's um the
evil villain or he's controlling or
whatever well we'll see that that's the
same way as a truman show when he finds
out he could leave god's pleading with
him no it's nothing but pain out there
this is perfect in here
so here's the lego movie
you might see a mess exactly and a bunch
of weird dorky stuff that ruined my
perfectly good stuff
[Music]
emmitt
thank you
and i just want you to know from the
bottom of my heart from this moment
forward i solemnly promise that i will
never
where's lucy
lucy
[Applause]
[Music]
wow that was all chaotic the bad guy in
the lego movie is actually a lego
personification of this boy's father who
said don't touch my legos he's got them
all glued together perfect the way the
instructions told him to put them
together but by the end he's like you're
right son let's unglue he's pouring all
the
the chemical to unglue everything and
they're just and you can just see the
chaos happening but it's the happy chaos
at the end
so here's the truman show and you'll see
the same interaction where
the god figure is trying to plead with
truman no stay in this perfect world
don't go out there into the darkness
[Music]
doctor
drew you can speak
i can hear you
i am the creator of a television show
that gives hope and joy and inspiration
to millions
listen to me tuna
there's no more truth out there
than there is in the world i created for
you
but in my world
you have nothing to fear
it's okay gentlemen i understand
i have been watching you your whole life
i was watching when you were born
i was watching when you took your first
step
you can't leave truman
you belong here
you're on television
you're live to the whole world
in case i don't see you
good afternoon good evening and good
night
[Music]
[Applause]
i really wonder if the actors recognize
the depth of this you know like
like here he is like almost in a
crucifixion prose stepping out into
outer darkness leaving the world that
god created for him
or the creator created for him you know
and it's like do they recognize that
like in a big picture sense
i've heard some of them some of them
mention that they are spiritual and they
are doing god's work they don't
understand i think the whole concept of
the bible
and the whole story that's being spread
out but they understand spirituality
but they're worshiping
they don't realize it the wrong god
and that's that's i think is the most
scary part when you have someone that
not only doesn't understand
what they're doing but
they also are spiritual
in the wrong sense they can do the most
damage
they're being totally influenced and
possessed
a lot of them will tell you yeah that
wasn't me out there doing that i could
have never acted that you know yeah i
went to my trailer and prayed you guys
got to watch actors channeling spirits
part one and two man this is not just us
being extremist like this is admitted
from the mouths of the
the directors the writers the actors
so i mean this is just
i mean the way they did this was so in
your face the sun rays and he's speaking
from the sky and he's saying i'm the
creator who brings hope and joy and
you know all these things
and don't go out there because i have a
perfect world for you i've watched you
since the beginning and it's just they
don't even hide it
so
i want to end with something that
scotty's actually looking into to make a
video on so be looking out for that but
here's a comparison you're going to see
it i'm not going to have to tell you
what to look for just watch a piece of
the beginning of this and then it's
actually going to show a side-by-side
comparison of lego movie as well
but free guy is the same story same
story over and over check it out
this
is free city
and the people who wear sunglasses
are heroes
they have a devil may care attitude and
they run this town
see
that's not even his car or his wife for
the sunglasses people they get to do
anything they want they go on all sorts
of missions they got cool hair cool
clothes
i mean laws aren't really lost to them
they're more like
mild suggestions like i don't think he's
gonna return that car or that nice lady
see what i mean
hero
my name is guy
and i live
in
[Music]
good paradise
i've lived here in free city my whole
life i've got a best friend i've got a
goldfish
[Music]
i mean that's just so bizarre yeah it's
so weird when you see it like that
side-by-side you're just like
yeah i feel like we're being programmed
or brainwashed yeah yeah that's how
mesmer mesmerism works yeah repetitive
repetitive repetitive until it gets into
your head subconsciously yeah so what's
the ladies character in there that's the
sofia
what's her name yeah
let's see i don't remember her name
either but she is she is the one that
kind of you know is the one that that
sparks him to make this change that he's
living in this
you know controlled environment um
what what is really interesting though
is
you have this lego movie which is
i i mean i would say mostly for kids you
know and this concept a free guy would
be more of an adult and so it's almost
like the same exact message is happening
with the kids happening with the older
you know and it's like different levels
of where people are in society are still
getting the same message
and he's saying the hero is the one that
does whatever he wants and the laws are
just kind of like mild
suggestions suggestions
i mean we see that even in christianity
man
and the creator um i mean we'll do a
whole breakdown because this free guy
was a really interesting i mean it was
paralleled to
what's going on in the world right now i
mean
so many scenes were
exactly like like a good representation
of what gnosticism is actually doing in
the media and so um i think it really
needs its full breakdown but the creator
of the video game
he's this evil guy that actually stole
the code
and uh so he was being shady and even
how he was doing it and then once he
found out that um that this
characters were wanting to do whatever
they wanted to do in the video game he
then needed to destroy the entire video
game so he took out an axe and he went
into the server room and he was like
gonna wipe them all out and i mean it's
yeah it's pretty it's pretty amazing how
you see
so much of these parallels over and over
and over again that there you have to
ask the question why what's the purpose
of this
i mean there'd be no logical reason to
see this kind of consistency if people
are just making this stuff up yeah
biblically god created two perfect
beings put them in a perfect world
and because of sin he's going to have to
destroy the whole world
yeah and they're basically a storyline
yeah bad light but who wants to live in
a world that's filled with rapists and
murderers and thieves and liars
you know well in this in this particular
one free guy it was like the more that
he stole the more that he got leveled up
he called it leveling up and it was like
you need to steal more you need to do
more evil you need to do these things
and that's what made him a more popular
person in the end which is which was
pretty amazing so
um yeah it's just a reversal of what the
bible's trying to teach you and that's
why i believe it's so important to to
you know
get your source of information about
your worldview and everything else from
from the bible i mean if you're getting
it from all this modern media you're
getting the wrong picture over and over
and over again yeah did you have some
key no okay
so i basically just want to wrap this up
with
these movies have an agenda look the
people from the matrix said we put a
spiritual gnostic message in there and
we wanted to draw people in through this
type of media
people say we're over analyzing it yet
you go search it out look up this movie
changed my life or uh you know this
movie explained and people will be
pointing out the smallest most minute
things and you read the comments people
are like wow that's amazing i never saw
that and they'll be talking about yeah
the director actually said he did it for
this reason that reason but when we
pointed out
we're over analyzing i think that's
that's just because there's a conviction
there you know we're actually
trying to get you to make
make an action stop watching this stuff
psalms 101 3 says i will set no wicked
thing before my eyes i hate the work of
those who fall away it shall not cling
to me
we're in a spiritual war guys there's
you're being influenced by god and
you're being influenced by demonic
forces and
and when you got these
glowing rectangles that are full of
action and and giving you this gnostic
story and you're drawn to that
for hours every single day and then you
look at your bible and you're like
i should probably read
a verse today or a chapter or something
you know it's just everything is a
distraction satan doesn't care if he
turns you into a satanist or turns you
or turns you over to the occult or the
new age if he can just distract you from
getting in his word it's the only source
of
of a weapon against him he is a powerful
foe and when he tempted jesus in the
wilderness jesus said it is written it
is written it is written
there is nothing that we can do
physically to fight we do not battle
against flesh and blood but against
principalities and the only source of a
weapon we have against them is god's
word so my appeal to you guys is make an
initiative this year we're still early
in the year make it your new year's
resolution to
get in start have a devotional life get
in the word of god every day even if it
is just a verse a day or a chapter day i
have a guy who sends me a text message
every day from church and i'm thankful
and i i read that and i i drive about 40
minutes to work and that's my prayer
closet time when i drive to and from
work set aside a time to get in god's
word and don't be so distracted that you
lose time with god because it's the only
thing that's going to keep us from being
deceived in these last days if you guys
were blessed by this episode don't
forget to click like if you're not a
subscriber click that subscribe button
don't forget to click the bell and leave
us a comment let us know what you think
about this also let us know if you see
any other movies that you see this kind
of theme in and share this video with
your family and friends and we will see
you guys next friday bye guys
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
is there any hope for me what can i do
to unify my family on not watching
harmful media how do i know my thoughts
are my own and how can i distinguish
between impressions from god i'm nervous
when it comes to sharing my testimony
that is really that important i stopped
watching mainstream media now what
sometimes we get a lot of people asking
the same kind of questions so we thought
it would be cool to make these little
videos answering some of them in a new
series called i got a question
concise answers to your media related
questions
we'd love to hear from you reach out to
us privately on our instagram page or
facebook
and if you don't use social media that's
all right send us an email through our
website littlelightstudios.tv
contact us
hey
we're here to help
we're here to help you let your little
light shine
[Music]
you